dans ces paquets une sélection de
fromages à destination d'un client
allemand pour ses enfants de fromagers
qui ont repris l'entreprise familiale la
vente en ligne représente un pari une
façon de se diversifier mais cela ne les
empêche pas de faire les marchés
cinq jours par semaine étape
indispensable pour attirer de nouveaux
clients
ces clients là vous les transmettre à
des personnes non sens large
c'est-à-dire leur famille qui était un
petit peu plus loin et vous voulez avoir
la possibilité d'envoyer il voulait
aussi par exemple ou simplement partir
en vacances avec son fromage sa guise et
du coup à la fin la possibilité de
proposer un plus grand nombre du fromage
et pour ça on a su être à l'écouté de
nos clients et essayer de proposer ça un
de plus dans leur entrepôt il conserver
afinde production de toute la france
notamment du fromage de chèvre du perche
fabriqués ici à frattini dans cette
exploitation 75 jet produisent chacune
900 litres de lait par an et tout doit
être transformé en trois matches n'a pas
de choix des fêtes il n'y a pas de les
trier par ici en épandre est brune
région un chèvre donc
l'obligation tous transformés en effet
d'aimant et il faut donc tout vendre
essentiellement sur les marchés ou
directement à la ferme le fromage du
perche a dû lutter pour se faire
connaître dans une région plutôt
céréalière l'exposition sur internet met
en valeur ce savoir faire
elles représentent de nouveaux débouchés
pour l'outil de yolande et jean-pierre
on est en phase de transmission
effectivement ça va se faire dans les
lois ou les années à venir et je pense
que cet outil a vraiment eu besoin
d'être développées et grâce à internet
il ya là et à la possibilité de se
développer
pour le moment les sites de vente en
ligne en sont à leurs débuts mais les
prochaines années seront peut-être l'air
de la biquette 2.0